not sure what's going on outside but
it's quite bright out there apparently
all right welcome back time for the
fastest first up
breaking news in case you didn't know
pierce morgan is extremely british and
we were talking in the break yesterday
about how seriously the brits take their
tea so we decided to have piers show us
the proper way i think this is a real
public service announcement first of all
i'm not taking it personally on my last
day on the the show you have none of you
have mentioned the fact it's my birthday
so we're just going to leave that out
it's all right you know now and it's not
too late for gifts but the
here's the problem with the way
americans make tea they make it too weak
or they overstew it but they never get
it right the recipe it's actually a
science and the crucial thing you take a
cup you have to put the milk in first
but if you then have to have
good proper tea this is hani and sons
english breakfast tea you'll get it in
all the finest establishments you need
to have at least one bag per cup and
then tossing in another one to get the
perfect texture which has to be a kind
of imagine being on a beach in miami for
two weeks that's the texture you're
after right so you take it here let it
stew for three to four minutes you stir
once after about two minutes and then
you should have
the perfect texture now that is too weak
so whoever put this in doesn't put
enough bags in should we finally have a
stirred it probably yeah do you think
that water was important
message to the women of america if any
man likes their tea white and weak like
this get rid of them maybe it will never
change maybe the water wasn't boiling no
no it's just it's the wrong texture no
appearance
yeah that's right but the crucial thing
it's scientific fact get the milk in
first
make it stew for four minutes not five
not three stir after two minutes have a
bag per cup and one on top wait a minute
it's in the pot yes yes when they're all
in the pot okay i'm making it the right
color that's really helpful do you like
builder's tea if you've read bills yeah
this is basically you like do you like
your spoon to be able to stand up the
best of all the teas is yorkshire gold
made in the north of england patrick
stewart from star trek got me into it i
ditched pg tips heartlessly and went for
yorkshire dog it's the best tea that you
will get but it's a proper science
because if you have a bad cup of tea
it's awful if you have a good one it's
so satisfying i mean it built our
country so do you like the flavored teas
or no no i don't like any of those and
nor do i like it without the milk you
gotta have proper good builders i think
the milk thing freaks me out i don't
want to put the milk in there i'm
withdrawing
no why no actually it's a scientific
fact so professor mackey from leeds
university revealed that actually in the
process by putting milk last after water
the tannings which you get in the which
produces the flavor will turn into
solids before they develop flavor
when you're attacking peers you're
attacking science if you put the milk
into i am the dr fauci of tea right and
when i tell you it's scientific it's
scientific so if you want to get the
tannins right and the taste and the
flavor right the milk has to go in first
does this look like the right color
we're getting this we'll see all right
one more thing here
there's more proof that machines are
taking over the world meet robo burger
it cooks and assembles two goat meals in
just minutes the robotic burger chef
plugs right into the wall features a
refrigerator automated griddle and even
a cleaning system greg your thoughts on
the room you know i have a theory that i
believe you can taste effort right
that's why your mom's sandwiches were
always the best sandwiches so there's
something about when you have a meal
made by a machine that means it's not
really made
it's not made with love therefore thumbs
down on the robot burger
would you eat one of these
no i'm not you know i'm uh watching what
i eat these days dana oh but i remember
i had a vegetarian friend growing up and
uh i always wanted him to trick him into
eating meat so one time my mother made
it a cheese sandwich why would you do
that and when he went to the bathroom in
my house i took a piece of turkey which
is very similar to the colored cheese
shoes and i slid it into his sandwich
and he ate it and i got it and did he
like it
you enjoy that he got something you got
a little okay well done
yeah but a robot can't do that no that's
true here's what do you think about the
robots are they coming to london too i
would think so i'll eat anything i don't
care who makes it um i'll just what
about the workers judge
i used to be one of the workers yeah
yeah i used to flip burgers and now look
at you and now i'm drinking tea that
appears more by the way now you've got
your pinky
can i tell you something yeah i like the
milk in it yeah okay i might try it
cheers
you have to go to the cherries
just how rude we are and one more thing
is up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else